vamos a actualizar las noticias
económicas con Juan Pablo lucum y Juan
Pablo saludo nuevamente acá estamos otra
vez Ángela seguimos con la que es la
noticia económica de la mañana con esta
reunión que se espera entre el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden y
los líderes del Congreso más
específicamente Pues con los
republicanos Así es pues y hay dos
puntos sobre la mesa que es lo que se
espera que discutan los republicanos
llegarán para defender su idea de que
haya recortes de gasto público mientras
se espera que la Casa Blanca defienda su
punto de que pues es trabajo del
Congreso aprobar el techo de la deuda
Sin condiciones como se ha hecho desde
1960 cuando se ha elevado cerca de 80
veces y es un discurso que han repetido
en varias ocasiones hay que decirlo en
Washington se habla que con este
escenario las expectativas de avance son
bastante bajas un asesor de la Casa
Blanca que habló bajo condición de
anonimato con el medio en bicinus dijo
que biden aún no está dispuesto a
negociar sobre el techo de la deuda en
Sí pero está abierto a discutir por
separado los recortes de gasto que
buscan como pues parte del proceso
presupuestario Quienes se sentarán en la
mesa con el presidente Joe biden lo
revisaremos a continuación porque pues
bueno acá tenemos los nombres está Shot
Summer que es pues el líder el líder de
la mayoría del senado Pero entonces
usted puede ver que del senado y la
cámara de representantes estará la
persona que irá a cargo de los
demócratas y de los republicanos está el
líder de la de La minoría que es el
republicano y para el lado de la cámara
de representantes está hacking que es el
demócrata pero el hombre crucial en este
momento va a ser Kevin mccarthy que es
con quien se ha negociado en diferentes
o bueno se ha hablado en diferentes
espacios y se espera Pues que se lleguen
a puntos clave en su momento él dijo que
yo vayan debería ceder en este escenario
pues vamos a ver qué pasa con esto Pues
que se va a seguir complicando Juan
Pablo Así es pero ahora vamos a revisar
como toda esta puja política ha afectado
a la economía incluso sin ese escenario
negativo de impago que todavía no ha
llegado vamos a ver en Pues que se ha
visto hasta el momento y podemos ver que
pues se pide recortes del gasto Federal
que evidentemente va a afectar a la
economía tiende las pujas entre los
demócratas y los republicanos hay
turbulencias en el mercado esto se habla
todo el tiempo y ahora lo veremos en los
indicadores como los escenarios empiezan
a estar temerosos un poco ansiosos de
este panorama la presión sobre la
reserva Federal que también Pues empieza
a tener dudas acerca de qué puede hacer
recientemente con las tasas de interés
mañana con el dato de inflación y la
crisis política que Es evidente Pues que
pueda ser como todo movimiento en este
escenario Pues en la casa blanca y
generar en el congreso Bueno pues los
republicanos harán todo lo posible para
negociar su margen y veremos hasta dónde
puede llegar esta puja entre tanto como
esta es la noticia económica del día por
supuesto que afecta el comportamiento de
los mercados así es y estamos con la
apertura de Wall Street porque abrió en
negativo muy atentos a lo que pueda
pasar en esta reunión del presidente de
Estados Unidos pero también pues el
mercado está temeroso y ansioso del dato
de inflación de Estados Unidos que se
conocerá mañana miércoles y por eso
puede ver los tres principales
indicadores en rojo las bolsas europeas
siguen operando en terreno negativo
movidas por las declaraciones del
canciller alemán Hola shorts quien dijo
que la Unión Europea debe acelerar los
esfuerzos para alcanzar nuevos acuerdos
de libre comercio las bolsas de América
Latina cerraron positivas el lunes
Argentina México Perú chile y Brasil
cerraron con ganancias Aunque la bolsa
colombiana se desligó de la tendencia y
fue la única que cerró con una pérdida
del 0,58 por ciento en Asia el cierre se
dio mixto con el principal índice de
Japón reportando ganancias Hong Kong
reportaron pérdidas
viene estábamos hablando de Asia ahora
vamos a pasar algunas noticias que usted
nos ha preparado de América Latina
empezamos precisamente con Venezuela Así
es empezamos por Venezuela porque el
presidente Nicolás Maduro dijo el lunes
que espera que la economía de su país
crezca más de un 5% interanual por
encima de la proyección que hizo el
fondo monetario internacional cuando en
abril la entidad rebajó 1,5 puntos su
proyección hasta dejarla hasta el 5%
centenares de productores agrícolas de
la región boliviana de Santa Cruz se
movilizaron el lunes en sus tractores
para protestar contra las restricciones
impuestas por el gobierno a la venta de
diesel importando de las gasolineras Y
es que el gobierno de Luis Arce importa
combustible a precios internacionales y
los subsidian el mercado interno
y la comisión de trabajo de la cámara de
diputados y diputadas de chile aprobó el
lunes el proyecto que reajusta el
salario mínimo hasta alcanzar de forma
gradual los 500.000 pesos chilenos desde
los
410 mil pesos actuales la propuesta será
revisada ahora por la comisión económica
y este desgarrador Juan Pablo tener que
seguir entregando malas cifras de los
empleos y las tecnológicas y hoy tenemos
los 710 empleos que recortará el link o
como es conocido acá linkedin pues que
es la red social que se centra en
Conectar a las personas con negocios
profesionales otra de las grandes
empresas que hace recortes a nivel
mundial Juan Pablo gracias a usted nos
vamos a directores